hi everyone
welcome to another ochoto tv video my
name is muffin do you ever think about
rage arts having shortcuts like there's
an option to turn it on or off and just
like watching a summon
final fantasy you think it's pretty cool
the first time you see it but you get
tired of watching it when you see it
more than a few times i mean in second
rage arts are pretty cool it hypes the
game up when you hit your opponent
especially at clutch moments
but it does get a little boring
especially when you're at the receiving
end kind of wish that you could just
press start to skip all the animation
and just go to the next round or maybe
it's happened to you before where your
opponent can just
jab you and that would do enough but
instead they choose to do a rage art
when you're just one pixel away
i mean there's definitely strategy to it
uh it gives you a chance to rest
especially in tournaments
work insult to injury with the rage art
at the end giving him some time to think
an online ranked it's used to protect
your rank
[Music]
this video is a delicious compilation of
characters that have
super long rage arts being uh cut down
to size that means you won't see some
characters like fang or kazuya which
ochoto and i both agree their radar
animation is just fine
i'm looking at you anna open wide i see
so yeah let's get on with it
[Music]
faith cannot be changed
you're right
[Music]
[Music]
hell yeah
come on
[Music]
[Music]
you're done
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two
let the darkness
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed that video leave a like and
subscribe or comment down below once
again this is muffin feel free to follow
me on twitter
and wherever your fighting game
community is if they're not
at the locals which makes a lot of sense
right now figure out a way to support
them as best you can
i believe in you you can do this uh
we're all gonna make it see ya
[Music]